all right and we are live
the last word with laura cognito and
ibottas friday evening campfire what's
going on is just a regular day right
yeah nothing happened this week in the
world of destiny absolutely nothing
um boring stop job completely so no
trailers no news no controversial topics
no we got a lot of stuff to talk about
but we had an awesome guest joining us
today so do what you do sir let's bring
this man
into the campfire let's go no doubt
what is up guys last word podcast here
and today
we are back in front of the destiny
campfire for some more lunar shooting
discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest
i had to do it to you so we gonna get
right into
i it to introduce the lord who is not
only one of the coolest titans and most
down-to-earth youtubers in real life
but his passion for the improvement of
the destiny franchise is truly unmatched
whether it be as detailed weapon and ray
guides or informative commentary
all done with outstanding production
values
damn introducing you ain't finished
introducing the created host of the
caccus hd
youtube channel and co-host of the real
gamer hour podcast
my fellow ufc brethren lord of twitter
memes
and with chick caccus the most creative
promoter of advanced gg
live from alberta canada and making his
return
at the realm of the last word
mommy lord rick cackus how you doing sir
gotta bring you right well dude i gotta
i gotta get you to do my intros normally
damn
just be like i got your 10-second
outsourcing fee check all right sweet
yeah exactly exactly what's good
bro how you been i'm doing well i'm
doing well i'm glad to be back and uh
yeah
dude crazy it's been a wild week for
destiny so there's a lot of stuff to
talk about
absolutely man so much going on man good
to see you so i know you you said you've
been playing a little bit of
gention in there but we are we back to
now getting into full time i know
i know there's been a lot of postmaster
controversy with you uh lately
um i want to talk about that
i was just like hey they should fix the
postman they should make it so that
it shouldn't a higher rarity item
shouldn't get pushed out by a lower
rarity item
and what i learned is no i'm an idiot
idiot how dare you
just use a third-party app after every
activity
what are you dumb like just just
after every activity go to the tower
that's normal that's no
that's not an issue all right it's not
an issue how
dare you demand stuff in games sir how
about you
fixing the postmaster would hurt
i never actually got i never actually
got an answer on that because the answer
is nobody
exactly but like it's like oh if they
fix postmaster then
then all the other glitches will run
wild in the game it's like bro they can
do more than one thing at once like i'm
sure bungie
there's like no guys we fixed postmaster
so you know what beyond like delayed
again i can't sorry the only option
it's rick's fault we had to delay it
it's my fault it's totally his fault
this is my fault no i mean i live in
that state with like either full
characters or full postmaster constantly
and then with humble and graham's this
season especially it's been
awful so because they give shaders too
and they just like really fill that up
and like what happened to me is i missed
one chest one strike chest
uh i got stuck in a loading zone and
missed it and it was like four
like blues uh legendary and an umbral
and then of course it drops the tokens
and the planetary resources which if you
don't collect them they go to your
postmaster
so it's like yeah no bungie 100 push out
my tennis senate shards and introduce
you know two dust-like shards that's how
they really want to be the hierarchy
you're looking for
yeah and but again it's like people need
to understand it's not about me
i'll get my shards back if you're a new
player and you're just like grinding
strikes and you don't know about dim
like you just got it from the xbox game
pass
you see a legendary you know it's going
to the postmaster you don't know it's
going to get pushed out by the blues you
missed
like i feel like those the people
getting screwed and it's like
you know one bad experience can can ruin
like if
you're missing an exotic drop or lose
something important as a new player
you're going to be like
i'm gone like i'm out of here yep that's
a good point that's a good point
eating life no i was like i mean new
players going beyond light we talked
about this previously
the story is going to be a little weird
if they go play forsaken be like who's
this kid dude we see for like five
seconds
new players are going to be in a weird
space they do have fast and furious man
coming in which will be good
um they actually get to spend some time
on one of our newish destinations that
we get to see but
i am kind of curious to see how the new
player experiences for beyond light at
least we get to go see what the shaha
experience
is going to be when we get in there so
that'll be kind of fun
but no like for this week we had so much
stuff come in
in and i swear it was just like oh you
thought this was it
here's an awesome trailer with an
awesome song that nobody could probably
play for copyright strike reasons but
like there's way too much fun but the
the real reason beyond like got delayed
is because bungie had to make like
45 trailers for this expansion like
honestly it's like gear
trailer story trailer another story to
your launch trailer pre-launch trailer
it's like bro
is there anything we don't know about
the game have they just played it all
for us at this point or
a little bit but we'll cover that once
we get there um
but biggest thing we got was the vidoc
that's what started everything
and i just kind of wanted to get you
guys like what was like a couple big
standouts before we're gonna go through
some pieces of it
what were some huge surprises and
spoiler warning for anybody watching
this or listening
everything's on the table from the vidoc
so if you're going spoiler-free at this
point you might want to duck out now
because it's all on the table so
just fyi but for both you and rick you
get to go first
seriously what stood out from the
viaduct to you what's got you the most
hyped so far
what you feeling rick what's going on
man to me to be honest like i'm gonna
disagree with you a little bit like i
felt like the
vidoc while it was awesome like if you
were someone who was paying attention to
the previous trailers and all the twabs
and stuff like i was like there wasn't
necessarily any huge
new information in the in the vidoc um
aside
from the season of the hunt stuff like
they
really didn't talk about that at all
until the vidoc and is you almost kind
of forget that
beyond light is also launching alongside
at like a ten dollar still like season
and then you'll have these
hive not cryptolifts whatever they're
called
kind of crypto lists yeah and they
they either come down or they spawn up
on the ground
and then there's like a hive boss and
stuff but the interesting part is like
that kind of that's really all they
revealed and it might be as simplistic
as that like if we think back to season
of the undying
it was pretty simplistic you had the vex
offensive right
yeah that's pretty much it the vex
offensive was the activity
and it had some gear associated with it
and that was pretty much
it um this time we kind of have the same
thing with those
hive structures and but the interesting
part is like you have this seasonal
quest that you start
and that's it like it starts on the 17th
i believe
and unlike all these other seasons you
know you have the season and it goes
away
this time apparently you're just gonna
be able to do that whenever
so like you can go back
potentially in like you could get in you
can get into destiny 2 in june
by season of the hunt maybe and then
start doing cryptos
yeah i never actually thought about the
buying of seasons because they said
that's the question yeah later but do
you can you
buy an old season that would be weird
that is a good question would it be
weird
yeah because i mean by icons like iron
banners everybody
donnings everybody but specifically
those like the
you know the uldren icon basically those
are like the season mission begins the
rathborn hunt begins those specifically
are and you're like
do you and again it's also you have the
tide of the artifact as well and the
reward that's got that same icon it's
like
you're not gonna go buy an old artifact
because that's gonna stay but how do you
kick off the rathborn missions in june
or something that's
potentially you can just like so the
interesting is if you look at the wrath
uh the
season of the hunt stuff it looks like
it's almost like a new public event
like it's just kind of happening in the
world it's not like its own activity
similar to vex offensive right so maybe
yeah it's just like literally
they're happening all year long and you
have to maybe buy it this
season and when you buy it you get the
loot associated with it
right probably and you can like earn
loot jobs
you can still participate but you won't
earn like the exclusive loot for it
potentially
like is that i don't know it's a little
confusing to be honest it it is a little
confusing
it is a little confusing i mean yeah i
mean i it
i'm curious about that like because
before we had like the what is it a la
carte kind of thing going on
yeah stuff like that so it is going to
be interesting to um see how channel but
i want to ask you
on break as far as like narratively
stuff anything narratively
with the trailer that hits you you know
specifically
positively or negatively well again we
kind of knew aldrin was coming back from
a while ago
uh because like the symbol shown in a
triumph screen was a symbol on aldrin
all the time
uh but yeah he's like for sure back
which is an interesting one
people keep saying like oh he's the crow
now he doesn't remember
who he is and i'm like i'm gonna i'll
jog his memory with
you know to the back of his head with uh
with a falling guillotine like
i'm uh i don't care that's a great sob
story dude you still got my glock to the
back of your head dude
thanks for killing me sir
with aldrin yeah like come on dude
yeah yeah sorry that's too bad dude
but like no it is kind of interesting
that they're bringing him back
uh because you know especially with
their relationship with
marsoff who is also still alive yes and
had a big part in forsaken to play and
we talked to her
so that relationship could be
interesting uh
yeah it's a cool it's narratively
bringing him back
i did that it was really funny where
like osiris is like the super powerful
world
c yeah and then he's like just like
knocks him down
it's like okay i don't have a warlock
yeah i know how i feel about those stars
with the disrespect
he's like smacked by a knight and just
like bam i ain't even going to got
backhanded and he's like collapsed
aside and then yo somebody did my man
dirty they put the life alert
on the bottom oh my god i said how are
you gonna do my man like
that's a good one but for aldrin i'm
gonna let it slide i'm gonna let it
stack because i want to see ultra gold
i was actually gonna ask you guys a
question would you i'd rather
this is the point where that like how
much stuff do people want to see in
trailers
and this is always the question of what
would you like to see and it's the
toss-up of
i know we have data miners and stuff
like that so part of it i understand is
like on day one some data miner is going
to get in there and it's like if you go
through the story mission you're
probably going to see it fast anyway
but i would much rather go through that
little cinematic moment which looks to
be in the hive
shrine of orcs or whatever that place is
called where that uh strike used to be
and it looks like he's sitting up there
and you're like oh it's osiris you're
talking to him for a second he gets
knocked down
in game to actually see older and walk
out for me would have probably even
better it's like i
lost my [ __ ] in the middle of the
trailer like i did
so i lost it in the middle of that but
in game we don't feel i don't feel like
we get that many moments in game anymore
because they're all done in marketing
yeah
so i was just kind of curious if you
guys cared if you'd like to see it held
or
kind of get with the interesting thing
is your opinion is
objectively the wrong marketing approach
and oh i know i hate
it i get that yeah it's it's i'm not
saying that
you're necessarily like well you are
wrong in terms of the marketing it was
just a weird thing
no no like i'm not trying to be mean
like i i almost have the same opinion
but uh i remember there was a study done
on movie trailers right and it's the
same thing
you watch an avengers trailer and it
basically gives away the entire like
movie or it leaves maybe some stuff out
but a lot of trailers it's like two
minutes and 50 seconds and it gives the
entire plot
but they've done studies and they
realize that when people know more going
into a movie
they like it better like they're more
likely to see a movie they know
more about if it's very ambiguous and
confusing
um and secretive that often doesn't work
so the same thing would be true for
these type of
gameplay trailers right where they're
they it's actually better for them from
a marketing standpoint to reveal
more stuff right which of course is
going to piss
people off but it's just like the
reality of just i guess how that works
yeah i mean you're making valid points i
mean i i definitely understand where
he's coming from because
you know from uh we're we're the
hardcore right we we love to have those
oh yo you seen when such you know i'm
saying like those moments
are insane but you're also write rick
like i understand it's this balance
right
you want to mar they want to market the
game they want to get people hyped from
this dlc to get people to pre-order or
whatever it is
and like you said it must be research
data that's showing
look even if you give that aldrin tease
or whatever it is right
as as amazing as that would have been in
game and we would have
knocked our socks off that will now get
a person who may have stepped away from
destiny and say oh yeah i remember that
guy you know what i'm saying yeah
into it and it builds the hype so it's
this fine line that they got to walk and
i definitely i definitely feel for my
man because i know where he's coming
from
but from a marketing standpoint it was
like because remember remember eat me
you had this discussion
with cadence you know similar it was
like
like it was a huge deal but everybody's
going to want to log in to see what
happens so it's like it's
marketing that's a perfect example could
you imagine
if they didn't reveal that and then just
like you watched kate died the first
part of her second you were like oh my
god
dude that would literally that would be
the most shocking moment of destiny
history honestly
but they but they used in all the
marketing stuff because now
it's motivating people to get in there
and avenge kade and stuff like that like
so that's
that it is kind of like an interesting
thing is how much they reveal
i mean like the raid they're revealing
almost nothing there's been
yeah there's like a landing zone and
like a walk through because there's only
a few places with like six people i've
seen in the trailer but
yeah like somebody who i was talking to
in chat because i was talking about this
the other night too and they said if
they want to get hyped for aldrin
but for me you also see like he's the
one dealing with osiris he's standing
there next to spider he's walking you
through the tunnels
like they laid out everything if they
could have just said hey shadow of the
hunt bringing it back characters from
the past and you see
like a glimpse of him do something to
know that he's coming as opposed to
he's here here here here and you're like
you know everything would have been kind
of give a little more question but
yeah yeah like did they have to show
the cinematic of him right right right
coming up that's a good point would they
could they have just showed like him
turned around and just a quick of his
place
yeah you could argue that that would be
good too and it would potentially be a
little bit more hype
behind it so interesting yeah
for me i mean look man the the vidoc
i was feeling it man like for me it was
more it was more of a payoff
to like we've always complained bungie
has all these loose threads that no one
go
that goes nowhere and so it it was
almost overwhelming
because in the beginning it was like all
right drifter
you know the stranger they all look so
awesome sorry
like everybody rocking in the beginning
right so i'm like okay cool then you got
the aramis thing going on we all know
aramis is a damn sub boss we already
know what's going on but what's that
i dirty boss yeah yeah storyboards you
already know what we're going to get
about it
but i did think it was cool the
motivations rolling up the the fallen
look where the you know we're going to
take this power we're going to you know
we've been betrayed by the traveler kind
of deal
i felt that aspect obviously we didn't
even get varricks too much in this one
but the thing that was dope was obvious
i'm gonna be real y'all know i'm a big
old cyrus warlock fanboy
i didn't think i was seeing him this
expansion so when i did see him
and i was like oh he's a major partner
i'm like he's dealing with hive it threw
me off
you know yeah now i ain't like my man
gets slapped the way he got slapped
you know he was disrespectful it was
funny as hell i gotta eat i got a whole
l on that one hey i'm gonna i'm just
gonna say this
osiris may have got slapped whatever
happens to zavala in the end
it's not going to be pretty so whatever
happens of all is probably not going to
be great if he ever goes down
the thing that was crazy for me was that
not only do you have all that going on
he's actually there was a screenshot of
him first of all you got two cabal
with zavala
that might be a little overblown because
he's with osiris they could just be in a
simulation
like it's possible it's possible i guess
mercury is
going away but like i mean
that's how i took it i was like maybe
there he like meets them in a simulation
or something
i don't know how that works or maybe
that's with kallus
kallus's uh boys and he's like
something's up we gotta see right we
gotta see is it red legion is it regular
it was
interesting that like in the luke smith
interview he said that for say
uh sorry beyond light is taking destiny
2
back to kind of where it was originally
intended yeah and like yes and europa
was one of the earliest concept arts and
now it's like okay
if this is like bungie's finally like
you know what there's no activision we
can finally
execute our vision for like what i mean
the crow was
yes the original kind of character you
saw and you saw
in the cosmodrome yeah in the cosmodrome
him as the crow in like the
teaser before it ever came out so it's
like they're kind of going back to what
they were and so now it's like okay
every old piece of concept art
you gotta and like old what was it
supposed to be is now like oh hold on
like this is quite interesting oh it's
it's awesome and the thing i like about
it
is again we got all these i didn't
expect the sheer amount of impactful
characters
all being involved the way it's been
prior has been you know you just deal
with one or two
and that's it now it's like all these
threads going on so i'm seeing i want to
see how they pay that off so for me the
narrative part
was lit the deep stone [ __ ] i definitely
want to know what's going on with that
because that's what the exos are made
so that was cool we got a little bit
more on the stasis thing but yeah i mean
i thought it was it was silent i thought
it was really solid
you know i got we're gonna talk about
season in the hunt and all that good
stuff but um e like i know because i did
a lot of reaction
i think you you waited i posted my live
reaction because yeah i was like i was
at work
and of course they've been started
dropping these trailers early and
earlier in the morning i'm like seven
a.m
i'm like i really want to go home but i
just i closed twitter shut my phone down
until i came home i was like i haven't
seen anything
and i was going through and i was like a
couple big ones for what it was the
cabal
sitting there with like osiris and
zavala was like i just need to
understand
how this situation is happening as you
said is it a simulation
are they working with them in some way
zavala and osiris like osiris got
that relationship yeah yeah exactly with
him kicked out the towers so those two
are cool so yeah
i i really do think it could be like a
callous situation like he
i mean you know we're kind of tight with
those cabal we i mean they don't fight
us when we load up there you know
but were they but were they religional
that's the thing was it regular cabal
is it because remember red legion is a
very specific faction
for them now that's the thing like and
it's it's so much going on i got so much
questions there
i mean we work with the fallen all or
all all the time uh like rocks
there's a bunch of fallen allies because
like every faction has kind of their own
except for the hive we just want to kill
everything basically but like
you know the fallen are not purely bad
and the cabal
kind of aren't purely bad either they're
just kind of there for the the glory and
war
type of thing yeah well they've solid
what was it they followed like the
shield brothers distress signal to
kind of us right from like destiny one
something like essentially yeah
yeah yeah but yeah i was gonna say for
me like it was
honestly it was really cool to see like
elsie or the stranger whatever you
want to call her she was kind of a bit
of a beast in the trailer just like
jumping around cloaking and everything
she was working
but for me like when i saw eris like and
then in the trailer the recent trailers
well when she pops the wall when she's
rolling a little ball on her arm and
when she's actually mid comp
she's just been like a storyteller for
us a standing figure
not moving to finally see her mid combat
action be like dude she's still got her
chops on her it's like
she's busy yeah she's working the
drifter does nothing in the trailer
he's still just talking um yeah
and then we got to see aramis literally
punch the servado to really get deep
into
their trying to you know cut their ties
with the servitors which is kind of like
their lifeblood like they're dependent
on them right yeah like that's a
symbolic moment for a fallen right yeah
that's why they all kind of freaked out
because
that's kind of their source of their
lifeblood basically so
that was legit and then of course for me
it was just like when they showed older
and for me it was hype just because i
was like
they're finally bringing them in we
finally get to see what's going on
because it's been two years
two years finally seeing some of this
stuff pay off which is really really
cool so
i was like as for like stasis powers and
varricks and the stranger
and aramis like we've kind of seen as
you said about 50 trailers going into
this thing but
yeah those couple big ones and then the
l i was i was gonna say
my last one was season of the hunt be
the fact that they said the words
zevo or wrath the third like
hive god so i mean you had all oryx we
killed sabathun's still doing her crazy
powerful death battery setting up the
dominoes thing they basically said in
the trailer
and now we're getting some hint of zebra
wrath get in the mix too
so building to 2021 is like expansion
that's that seems like the big one yeah
how many how many of these hive gods do
we got to kill though like at some point
all of them dude honestly at some point
i'd be like you know what
it's not worth it like i'm a chip you
don't want to kill zola to strike again
yeah like honestly though like so crota
i know he's not like kind of a god but
crota then oryx comes and controls all
the taken and we're like
peace dude kill him and then zol and
then
um starts with an n
nakris he's not is he not really god
yeah he's like a necromancer dude
so again it's like it the extended god
family
and it's like dude i mean no wonder no
wonder they're mad at us
oh yeah we're just chopping that family
tree down
like we like we write daughters yeah but
in fairness they were like right next to
oryx
yeah right before they showed up
something you gotta be careful who you
hang out with that's just what that is
yeah at some point like is it worth it
is it worth it to take what are they
trying to do even take over earth
i guess kill the traveler yeah yeah
that's the source of the light versus
the darkness and if they're all from
like the deep and the source of the
darkness
maybe but again hopefully now as we're
finally getting to see some of these
stories we actually get to see what
that's all about
the universe is pretty i don't know big
like they could just go somewhere else
like i'd be like dude we're losing a lot
of guys here like why don't we just yeet
off
to some other undiscovered planet and
we'll just chill there like i don't we
don't have to
mess with these guardians anymore
weirdly powerful i don't know
why they just don't want to die yeah
literally dude yeah but the thing the
thing i think that threw me off with the
whole um what is it i can't pronounce
that damn
he or help me every time whatever the
hell um yeah okay yeah the sister
the sister right i didn't think we would
get
that story beat at all to be honest
especially in beyond like so my thing
was
and the way they make it seem is like
the ambitions of
this this sister is different from
savathun so that's another
god of war for them basically right it's
it was interesting i didn't expect that
storyteller so again it's so much my
only concern if i gotta get picked okay
i gotta get right
oh no go ahead not just saying my only
concern if i got a nitpick
is there so many people going on there's
so much threads going on
how do they pay this off you know what
i'm saying because
obviously this campaign it looked like
it's gonna be rocking i'm gonna see how
long it is
but again i just i'm my only nervousness
is again
classic bungee you know we just want to
make sure we get proper payoffs for
certain things
do i do i expect everything to conclude
no but
i would like it done cohesively and
stuff that makes sense instead of
somebody just making a cameo appearance
and then you don't see them you know i'm
saying like i want it built right and
that's my only concern but get right
well i was just gonna say like okay so
the god of war isn't even around yet
like what are the other
people have been doing it seems like war
to me like what
this one's gonna be mega war it's like
dude
he literally have already been warring
with the hive constantly
but it's like now the god of war is here
for more war it's like i don't know
i i'd like to see the interesting thing
is like
so now we embrace the darkness
it's like okay so why do you still want
to kill us if you're on the
darkness side i mean i guess yeah the
hive just need to kill everyone
i guess it's interesting it's
interesting right
the and the payoff seems to be this
witch queen and then
light fall and it shows the big pyramid
and it shows the sphere the tower behind
it
so it's like basically the pyramid ships
getting to
earth getting to the traveler um no i
feel what you're saying you're making a
good point because e like
in a sense we're we i mean they are
confirming we're going to embrace the
darkness and use this against them right
so again to to to rick's point if we are
doing that action
right then why are the rest of them
beefing without
we're basically joining with them in
some regard
right so the vibe i also get they they
kind of allude to
factions in the sense of some race is
saying hey i don't know
some race is like yo we should embrace
it you see that exchange between zavala
and eris like
i was like nah fam like we're not going
over and she's like no we need to see
what's going on
so i think that my guess is that's what
they're trying to set up this whole
you know all the different races and
they're all different groups
having different motivations as to
whether accepted or not what are you
thinking
uh i mean shout out to some of the lore
people who are a little smarter than me
on this in my chat i mean they're
basically
what they're saying they like infinity
war it's going down oh yeah i mean
that's
that's what it seems like we're getting
to with sabathune
that was the thing when we had biff
actually on the show was the fact that i
was wondering because like it seemed
logical with the witch queen like
we get a new destination but it's also
for their resources
reusing the dreadnought seemed like a
logical thing as well
so i wondered honestly when that might
be coming he said we probably will never
see sabathune because she's the
trickster and she's going to find some
way
to be a proxy to everything that we're
doing so she's never directly involved
and we know she's going to be involved
now and the fact that we actually have
zubarath her sister building up to this
as well for over the course of
probably all the season zevarath is
going to be somehow tied to these things
of what we're doing
i i mean the whole infinity war
everything coming together
i honestly wonder how which queen is
going to handle
everything that happens in there and
then how it can escalate from savithoon
who
who we've been building to for so long
what do you do in lightfall that makes
it even bigger than the witch queen
that's i guess the question unless we
finally meet the veil but
anything it should be that right yeah
but i was like is that how they go into
is that when they finally just take the
drop off the two or do a d3 is that how
they lead into that or is that when they
ever build into what's next is like a
new race i hope
that this is the time where i wonder
it's like it at the end of year nine is
this the point where they're like
they're gonna hang up the bungee uh or
the destiny like robe on the wall and
just leave it there or is that where
they're like cash cow's still going
we're gonna keep going i guess we'll
just have to see but
it's such a big and ever evolving game
it really doesn't seem like they have
plans like
stop supporting it yeah right they they
are making a new game so like they're
trying to branch out and do multiple
things at once spongy
yeah but like you you can't give up i
don't think you can ever really give up
on destiny especially now that they have
their own creative control and they can
do what they want with it
um it's they might who knows if they do
some spin-offs it might be a
destiny warzone coming at some destiny
royale
who's good who knows right if the
hardware gets there then it might be
able to handle 50 supers at once but
until then
yeah well last point i thought was
interesting was i love when i looked at
the road map
you know we saw this this rathborn hunt
and it looks like we're definitely
taking
place on the dream in city right so you
know that i want to see if we get some
payoff there because
it was interesting to me that or the
dream in city wasn't removed from
obviously the into the content vault
it's still going to be a part of the
expansion
so i want to see what they do there
obviously we got the old we got the
mauro soft things we got the curse
we got a lot of things that got to get
paid off and i want to see how they use
that space
from beyond light going forward so
that's where i'm at with it too but yeah
got a road map of you know the hype
trains going man and it goes till
february which i guess answers like
you know what normally they launched
that other uh
season in uh december
now it's gonna launch in february which
like
so what is it the other one usually
launches in march so if they're pushing
that back probably be early february
march like maybe we have a launch in
like april or may instead of
june yeah but then you gotta fit one
more in still
so maybe end of april just and then you
have one in like
august or july yeah i was like do they
start shortening like the
post beyond light seasons are those a
little more condensed to get back to
their
site if they're trying to do it again i
don't know it's interesting like yeah
will the the two be condensed and so we
have the normal like june launch for the
normal summer shenanigans
or instead of a june like a later june
or even an august launch and they're all
a little bit shorter which honestly
would be better it would just
be more packed with content right yeah i
just wonder what that's going to do with
them on like their dev cycle too it's
like
they're looking to build towards witch
queen which is when we're looking at
things like cross play
and all that stuff coming up and like if
they try and condense that window from
like november
to get back to september it seems tight
for them as
you know development's not easy anymore
no
but the you know the seasons are usually
a bit lighter
yeah and it seems like now especially
there may be i might say even later but
like you know with
the season the hunt seems you just have
these public events and probably a few
things of loot and that's kind of it so
it's a good question
it's a good question right because at
the end of the day that's where
the delay you know going in had to
affect the development of the next
following two
annual you know passes or whatever so
yeah it's a good question
does it get shorter does it get longer i
i was speculating that potentially they
just
get rid of one of the seasons and just
have two more condensed
seasons yeah uh now that would kind of
screw up a lot of the timing
and screw up the infusion caps right
because it's like supposed to go a
certain amount but you get rid of one
how you gonna do that
that's the interesting part or they just
skip one and say
you know season 13 14 and then witch
queen's 16 and we're skipping 15
too bad you know i don't know it's good
i don't
it's like most likely they're gonna
condense them but it could be an
interesting move
the condensing wouldn't be bad because
there's plenty of times in any of the
past year when it's like
could we take some weeks out of this
yeah like get him out of here we don't
need like
the fourth iron banner i'm good and then
but then like or like this season
this season when they when they have
when they have
like three weeks of nothing and then
they have
the halloween event go live and the
interference mission finally complete on
the same day
well the reason why is because obviously
they have like you know certain update
chunks and they do everything in one
thing but it's like
guys a hundred percent the interference
mission should have become like
two weeks earlier or whatever so
everyone can get hyped about that and
then you have the halloween event as its
own thing
right yeah and then we still have to
allude to this
you know i don't know i don't call it
like an almighty event but some type of
season ending event that got to
transition into or you know
what you call a rival so and ender i was
into beyond light so that's another
thing
it's i feel for them because i know they
didn't anticipate that delay
and now they have to kind of scramble
and then still get things lined up
but yeah there's still some payoffs that
that need to happen so i'm curious to
see how they
handle that and then transition in but
we got a lot of 12 some stuff to get
into man
let's get to an e yeah i'm just trying
to think is there anything else from the
vidoc that you guys like
were hyped about anything that you guys
saw i like the audio stuff was cool as
like that's always stuff you don't think
as much about but when we're playing i'm
always just like
if you take a second like how does this
sound
and they had that weird giant long like
horn looking thing that she's like
rolling a slinky on them like the way
people come up with sounds like audio
engineers are like
really really out of the box thinkers we
did get confirmation of double buddy
so we got the yeah no time to play yeah
you you and your warlock double arc
buddy are you gonna have a little [ __ ]
yeah get my getaway artist if i join
y'all saying get the gag at the gang
people who are solo players can't
complain about not having a fire team
now
just make your own two buddies yeah yeah
probably more useful than having you
know half the fire teams out there
honestly
right oh
throw it directly at them and they hold
it and then they're like and then they
just like throw it into the
into the distance you're like all right
so go ahead i'll just do it myself it's
fine
so let me let me ask let me ask with
this because you know this is rare to
eat
i got two titans around me so i gotta
ask the titans how are we feeling
about these exotics that you saw on the
trail like how are you are you hyped
the one that makes you overshield yeah
yeah yeah where you at dude
busted his crap dude what the hell
like apparently uh like i think there's
probably gonna be some sort of weight
about
obviously uh the there was some
speculation i was saying originally okay
so if it replaces your
if it replaces your class ability does
having stuff that affects the cooldown
of your class ability
then affect the cooldown of that or is
it just like it recharges in 20 sec or
30 seconds or 20 seconds
no matter what and so your was it
like resilience would it matter right
it's gonna be very interesting
but like just for the fact that it's
like okay just pop it
come around the corner win that gun
fight
bro yeah i mean the only thing is no
crucible well you can probably you can
hear it and you've got a big animation
so if you hear it
yeah it's like don't go around that
corner
it's like when you hear a golden gun
activate i'm just gonna like see you i'm
i'm
i'm i'm not like i'm not gonna deal with
this uh
but yeah it seems cracked uh
there a lot of the exotics seem really
good the one for the warlock
that increases burn damage
and i think it just said increased burn
damage period which like okay
remember when that happened viking
funeral and d1 yeah
that like so grenades are gonna be
affected by that too and i think it also
said like if you kill enemy with burn
it uh it recharges faster or whatever
and again is that effects
energy yeah or your melee recharges
faster but again like that affects
multiple things you throw a solar
grenade sunspot grenade or whatever
that causes a burning effect so that's
also going to affect it
and then if you're on bottom tree sun
dawn that's a pretty good pve subclass
so now
that's doing more damage more damage and
continually because the more kills you
get it extends the
exactly that's already seeing play and
now
you're gonna do more damage like that's
interesting i will say like the uh
the poison grips the necrotic grips or
whatever i knew that's exactly what that
was
like you get a group of low-level ads
you punch one and just as they die it's
just going to trickle and change that
damage to everybody
that impressed me way more than that
that's an interesting one and then of
course obviously giving hunters blink
which is the worst idea ever like
can we play titans
we're gonna need our shield because
they're gonna literally dodge next to us
slow us down and we're gonna have to
take all those shots because we can't
all that happens you you aim at a hunter
aim with them for two seconds they just
spam jump
and then they convince them skill
themselves they're like wow bro i smash
that
space bar such high skill gap i'm so
skilled
it's like no dude you're just a wimp no
i know you're supposed to do that i'm
just a salty ass titan who just gotta
look up all the time i'm like yeah there
you go
all right i'll respect the heart i i'm
i'm just salty honestly because that
looks extremely powerful
like even blink you have more
of a like trail right you blink here and
it kind of shows
you to hours yeah so you can kind of
track it better this seemed like it was
like literally like
gone and it appeared somewhere else and
that's gonna be really hard to track
yes and so even like just sideways in a
gunfight you're getting shot at
boom now i'm over here i keep shooting
you and uh
that could be a really interesting one
can't wait till that's disabled three
days after the expansion comes but also
like you have one
for hunters and i guess that's how they
balance it out because that one seems so
good
and then you have the one that nobody
can pronounce arthritis embrace or
however you say that thing
whatever with the double bouncing
throwing knife i'm like that is
literally just a montage thing i still
do not see the purpose in that
no but i guess if oh oh oh oh oh i'm
going to interrupt okay
so on the website the description is
bigger than what was on the trailer
really what is it so
this is why you got to watch my content
look at the rapid precision so with yeah
so that's the thing that makes it rapid
precision hits
increase weapon damage and it's like
wait a second
that is a huge deal because like rapid
precision hits
increase weapon damage and then just the
the precision knife bouncing or the
knife bouncing is just like a little
extra thrown off
and that blows my mind because it's like
okay if i'm using
an auto rifle will that maybe make it
one
shot less to kill or something uh you
know if i have a scout rifle will that
make a four shot kill a three shot kill
right probably not because that would be
extremely powerful
a fast firing auto rifle where it takes
like 10 headshots to kill
that maybe would be reduced but then
it's like okay in a pve scenario
like hold on and also how
like is it ascending like this or is it
just like one tier so it's like hey you
land five percent shots
10 more damage flat plateau after that
right
if it ramps dude thunderlord is gonna be
the next meta for damage or
you know a fast firing sniper okay so
what if i'm using something like the
aikilo sniper that's got like you know
you can shoot like what 11 rounds with
that
so if that's ramping up in damage oh so
yeah just that ability is like peaks my
interest like crazy
i misread that i thought that was
related to like somehow like rapid knife
precision hips i'm like that doesn't
even make sense so that actually that
clarifies some because when i just read
that i was like
i read that the first time like that
that makes even less sense but if it's
just true exactly damage that's honestly
could be
it just says changing times yeah
yeah and that's the hits is why what
makes it cracked out of his mind for pve
because that
hey it affects boss damage i mean if
your boss dpsing with
the whisper of the worm the aikilo
sniper zeno i mean xenophage doesn't
really create but
right and those things you could put on
a helmet that just makes you do
flat more damage and like what are you
using right now on a hunter maybe you do
celestial nighthawk but then you've kind
of got to take time away from shooting
to do that
so this could be like this is one of the
potentially one of the most impactful
news exotics period the key of is it
going to be a flat damage increase or is
it going to be a multiplier where that
time's up
it keeps going up yeah it could get
crazy stack one stack two stack three
and just everybody plays hunter and like
bosses there yeah like that'll be
yeah literally that was just kind of
titan's complaining that was because you
totally will
type this game oh completely warp the
medic
that was like an oppressive darkness and
a bubble buff
that's going away right probably yeah we
know we'll get something but yeah they
probably won't bring it back at first i
would imagine
we do get yeah we get the name of the
new strategy he said heir apparent gonna
be meta yo the chat
i mean if it stupid i mean i i feel like
it's gonna be like
after a certain amount like after four
precision hits you get like a ten
percent damage increase and a plateau
it's kind of like even then that could
be a big deal yeah yeah
we get one strike yay
for now yeah all the strikes taken away
but we got one new one
we lost seven but over the course of the
year we should get four this one and
then the three on cosmodrome right
um yeah
i think there's one more europa one
that's coming at some point or something
like that
oh maybe maybe it's like maybe it's
gonna be similar to
the raid i swear there was two on europa
but like remember when we beat the raid
then
i think
i think they may be doing something like
with that because of it takes place
in like uh like a similar kind of in the
deep stone crypt
because like something i notice is if
you go on the website
it says deep stone crypt it literally
doesn't even mention the rate it's like
deep stone encrypted it's
almost listed as a new area i mean i
watch i watched your video sir yeah
and you actually will only one of the
few
to make a very good point that most
people are just assuming deep stone [ __ ]
is just this one
area and you made a good point like this
could be a very large
area right and that the raid is in in
this new area as opposed to just
the deep stone crypt being one singular
thing so continuously because
yeah i i don't think it's necessarily
what is panning out twice i don't think
it's necessarily going to be a new
like uh you can travel to it because
they kind of would have said that
in order to sell the expansion but
certainly just the way it's like
really weirdly worded like yeah i'm
looking back at some of the other
you know dlc's and you know for
uh scourge of the past they weren't like
new area first city they were like
scourge of the past raid takes place in
the for in in this
last city they didn't list last city as
just a new area you're going to but they
did with deep stone encrypt and so i
think like
it's very possible that a strike takes
place there or potentially it's
something like leviathan
where you go in and do the raid but then
there's like potentially some more
places you can go
some chests you can find secrets it's
got the whole
it's got the whole under underbelly area
right you can go and get loot there like
pretty unrelated to the raid even though
it's not like a fully travelable
you know destination right so i think it
could be similar to that honestly
that would be cool i'd actually that
would probably be the best thing i could
see because it does seem like that i
mean the raid is deep stone crypt but
seeing more explorable
because so many people have questions
about that destination and like if you
could explore and find little lore bits
or anything like that would actually be
really cool for that area that a lot of
people are looking forward to
understanding more about an entire race
like this is where we're actually
finally going to get to see stuff about
the exos and that's actually the first
hell
uh and clovis you i caught that clovis
braid law stuff right that's been
dropping
and the um yeah i got my lunch box over
there what are you talking about
i forgot yeah you know i'm not privy to
such information hey you could have
pre-ordered it really
that's your choice i'm sorry i'm living
through you sir
there's a whole book in there that would
take like an hour to read so you got
yeah grey stuff is deep man your man is
he's wow your boy's wild man pushing
those um
experiments to the limit man but we will
get into it yeah cause we listen to milo
and talk about that that man is a little
crazy
um yeah yeah crawfish is crazy yeah it
worked
we got access something worked all i can
say is i want
i want the x i want these strangers fish
thingy whatever it is and whatever ship
lands with those like interstellar robot
rotating sections like the ones that
look like it's the right the
tars guys exactly i want that ship
because
if that's her ship she's got the best
looking loot in the entire game like
hands down
yeah i i that is that phil fish thingy
was quite interesting
of like maybe that's just like an exo
pet i feel like looking back at it
but well maybe that's something one
point right weren't they like asking
luke and be like well it's not a ghost
he's like and you won't be able to get
it
for a while or something like that he
said it's i think it's like they're
at some point we'll get like pets and
destiny okay
i really do and then and they'll they'll
kind of like trail along or like
like a ghost you only see when you take
it out right so
it's just like a nice piece of
customization you know more content and
everest if you know what i'm saying
if you may as well just get they're
getting more generous now with the
brightness yeah we gonna get it
kind of for some for the average person
they will definitely probably see more
for the hardcore grinders
it's likely they'll actually see a
little bit less so you kind of got both
sides depending on the person playing
but yeah the season pass is sadly for me
even i said this a while ago i was like
can the season pass get like a bit of an
update a change
nope not really yeah we're just getting
basically more
bright dust thrown in there and
everything else is probably going to
look pretty similar
now the season pass is going to go from
what 2500 to 10 500 bright dust which is
a good thing for like
you know casual person logs in they just
want to play some strikes they do their
normal stuff they don't do their weekly
bounties they're going to get a
crapload more but then you have the
people who have three characters go do
every weekly bounty and they want to
farm for bright dust and this is like
this is the game i play they're
definitely getting like
what somebody did the math there's like
almost 30 percent less bright dust that
you can earn in a season potentially the
way the weeklies have been lowered
just kind of curious if you guys cared
about this one good bad or other i don't
really do
that hardcore weekly is like i'm not
going to be i'm not fun to play gambit
every week like come on dude i'm not
gonna do that
like the bright dust just ain't worth it
for me so i i think yeah for the
vast majority of players it's an
increase if you're like
going super super hardcore i guess it's
a dick but it's it the weekly bonds go
from
200 down to 100 right so you still can
grind them and also
you've got to factor in that they seem
to be every time there's like um
you know an event that offers a lot of
bright dust
right and so we know the dawning is
coming too so you'll
potentially be able to make up some
bright dust that you
maybe would have like lost uh if you're
like a super hardcore bounty farmer
right yeah i was like it's probably a
short group of people
i guess my only thing was for them for
the person who's like i'm gonna play
your game and i'm gonna be livid in
there they probably have one or two
other people they may do that with as
well
and it's just like it would be nice for
them to reward those people and they say
they're going to work on stuff in season
13 so we'll have to see what the changes
are let them have more than
10 ascended shards then there's a lot of
changes if you want to go down that
rabbit hole
yeah i agree that like
bungie seems to not like we can't let
players get
too far ahead we can't yes we can't let
our dedicated players
be too like have too much stuff because
then
oh no they'll be able to mass work all
the new exotics and it's like and
and like okay the guys like plays like 4
000 hours like he's gonna beat you in
the crucible whether or not his new
exotic is masterwork so just like
let's let players get lost in the world
and lost in the game and
and and get some benefits again like the
most of it is pretty minor benefits the
difference between
if i have a if i'm in the crucible and i
have
a uh one-eyed mask and you have a
one-eyed mask and mine's masterworked i
get
some very slight advantages right so
there are advantages but they need to
stop like i
really think they need to and and and
with
adept weapons they seem to be moving
into more let's let the hardcore players
be hardcore
because those weapons look freaking
sweet and
just yeah those plus three to all those
other stats like that's the perfect
example of like
it is technically a tiny bit better some
players don't want that like
there is actually i you know obviously
talked about how there should be a debt
weapons back
yeah a lot of players like didn't want
that they're like no you good players
just want to dump on us
casuals even more it's like dude that's
not the place
three plus three stability is really
almost not gonna make the difference in
any gunfight
like it you know it's it's like
it's that carrot at the end of the stick
that trials needs
exactly and i don't think casual players
realize that like
yes this is a piece of loot dedicated
for the hardcores but it will help them
because then all the hardcores are
chasing adept weapons and guess what
you have a debt weapons nobody and i
mean right
nobody hardcore is farming tokens at one
to three wins anymore
because they're going for those weapons
now every time dude there's no
way you can tell me you can get an adept
shotgun or
oh you can go and get tokens like so
that means like
the beginning wins are gonna be
for the most part three of hardcore
players yeah they're going to be near
the top
so it just got easier for most players
to go in and get some tokens and be more
casual in trials and get some loot there
no i agree i agree and at the end of the
day like i've always said you know it's
an
end game activity right you know at the
end of the day we just can't be just
giving out
everything to everyone because like i
always say vanilla d2
suffered from that and it really
bothered me that people were getting
raid weapons and all this other stuff
like at the end of the day this is an
endgame content if you're not good
enough that's fine we still got
confident we still got all these other
things for you
or you can aspire to be better so i'm
not trying to be bougie
but at the end of the day it's like we
have to reward the hardcore and give
them incentive
to want to chase that yeah it's like i
mean it's the same thing with the raids
they're getting the tease of that and
that's kind of hopefully they kind of
handle the raid socket and stuff
correctly and there's a little bit of
that stuff coming in as well
but overall it's just the in-game stuff
like
i can go out and get a piece of armor
that's exact same as a raid piece of
armor it's like why am i gonna go get
that
exactly well that was destiny one right
like the the armor just looked different
that was it and it didn't work
the game like completely collapsed on
itself because like people
the casual players a lot of the time
like
don't realize some of the finer aspects
of the game and gain development they
just
are in they want the cool loot and then
they dip right
right but it once you do you know
even if you're kind of well even if
you're a casual player get some time off
you spend a few solid days playing the
game
you really start to grind up you can
even start to really
feel those end game pressures like or
you luck out and on
a streamer carries you through a raid
and you got some raid loot and you
finally ascend
like something that i think it's
a lot it's very hard for people to
realize is like you need aspirational
content
even if you're not beating the raid even
if you're not beating trials
you need just the knowledge that it's
there because
that's what you're working towards i and
it's
again you're not really going to notice
it too often but i noticed that recently
in borderlands 3 because
in borderlands 3 they changed a bunch of
stuff i was playing it recently having
fun but it got to the point where i was
max level and had some decent loot
and i was just like had that sudden
realization of
what next and there is nothing like all
of the takedowns are a joke and they're
not even close to a raid
there's no raid bosses in borderlands 3
like there are in borderlands 2.
you had nothing to work towards and i
literally just stopped playing after
that
like it wasn't like i i was like mad and
i logged off i just logged off and i
never got back on because i was like i'm
basically done like i beat the game
there's nothing for me to go for
so as soon as you remove those hardcore
activities
casual players even if they're not doing
it they'll they'll stop playing too
because there's no more
like why are you getting loot why are
you getting god rolls if not to
eventually maybe try trials
right like why else would you want that
pvp god roll
you're muted by the way lord preach
that's why i was literally so angry with
vanilla d2 because again
everybody got everything and then like
you said once the casuals get everything
they're out and that majority of the
base then goes away so without the
aspiration out of the cars go by so
without the aspirational content
you know what i'm saying like there's
there's no incentive and the thing that
people don't realize like
i got t.e you know i told you this story
all the time is i'll never forget in d1
i didn't know what trials was
right and then going into the tower and
seeing some
god the guardian with all this egyptian
girls like what the hell is that
you're like and i'm like yo what's
doctrine of passing and
oh yo i got it and i sucked that pvp but
it
made me get in there every week whether
it be just doing those little grind
bounties and so on and so forth
that's the thing you need and and people
like
that because that's what people have to
realize has to be the game continue
and well it's also you're 100 right but
it's also designed with those baby steps
like i'm sure you did some of the
bounties and got you didn't get the
adept messenger but maybe you got the
normal message i got a regular i got a
regular doctor to pass it and then i was
like yo
i gotta get next level i gotta level up
and yeah and it's
slapped though you can still gain
benefits from that loop but then you're
like okay what if i get it adapt you
know what i'm saying like
and it's just that little like you have
you need something to play
for you can't have all this stuff to
perfect your build
and then nothing to use your perfected
build on yes
preach well that's even why like i mean
it's nice to see like
dungeons haven't solo like incentives
and kind of built around that because
those
you do kind of need to spec out for to
survive to a point but also like i still
even miss like hard mode raids
because that was that like you'd go
through you like king's fall was still
one of my favorites for
the reason of it was built hard they
took it down to normal
and then as you learn the encounters you
got some gear out of there you got some
more and that's where it's like
they the gear hopefully i'm hoping maybe
in deep stone crypt
has some benefits to the raid itself and
it needs to like if i get gear from
the deep stone crypt hopefully it has
some benefits to there outside of those
mods that we're gonna get to see
so no the carrot needs to be there for
all of these in-game pieces so people
have a reason to continue
otherwise especially now as you can sit
in a strike playlist and get to 1250
they need to have a reason to go get
other stuff that's better than just a
number
and that's what yep and that was the
biggest thing with avengers is there was
nothing to do after you got like you got
your skills like you got your skills
which is like a fun way to play it was
just changing a number and nothing
changed and i was like that's what sucks
so no doubt and like that's part of the
it's crazy like part of the reason
destiny is so successful is because
they're not listening to a huge amount
of players and
who are like put in matchmaking for
raids like do all this stuff
and bungee's like nope and
and and yeah they don't like it but like
psychologically
even if they don't realize it like they
have that light at the end of the tunnel
they have something to always aspire
towards
and it's just so important because yeah
like you said with avengers
with anthem with borderlands you all
these games you level up level up level
up and then you kind of like
what's next exactly exactly i have my
build
yep what yeah exactly yeah
preach it brother preach it no five yeah
those guys
sir i was like well we're touching
through pieces of it i mean we know the
level caps gonna be basically as we
expected the infusions going up 200 on
everything so that's not new uh but the
nice thing is they did do the powerful
reward changes so now you can go sit in
strikes gambit crucible seasonal drops
which will be whatever season the hunt's
going to be
you'll have a chance from those to get
powerful rewards now they say it's still
more efficient to go through the
powerful
challenge checklist and do them all but
if you're like i'm out and you have like
a one player character especially he's
like
i've got one character i did all my
challenges what do i do this week now
you can go sit in those activities if
you want to
and still keep leveling up so there's
incentive to continue to play the game
which is going to help especially that
one person who's working through it
what's up
the key is going to be the frequency of
those correct yeah that's the big one is
it like
one every 10 strikes oh hell no it's
like like one every couple or a few or
something then we might be talking but
it all depends as you said the frequency
because if like i've done 10 strikes and
i got nothing this is not worth
it yeah that's that's a whole different
story entirely
um tokens yeah i mean tokens collections
those are pretty much being nerfed into
the ground
collections too like i was even thinking
about exotics like they're gonna be
capped at 10.50
everything's going to be 10.50 first off
like every piece of drug that you own
but like even exotics from collections
like oh you know it's like hey i want to
go through toy run with this exotic it's
only like 20 below
nope even your old exotics that you like
pulled out to use you're gonna have to
infuse them all to go use them towards
the end because they're not gonna be
nearly as close which
is a little annoying i don't know why
that stuff's quite as low but yeah i
i already know what they're doing with
that we got it i don't see why you can't
the the
withdrawing stuff in the collections
can't also be 20 below right
hey i feel like it's like problem solved
and it makes it more fun
like oh you know i'll do it a lot where
it's like hey it's um
arkburn whatever i'm just gonna get the
risk runner no i'm not like
that like i'm not gonna have to infuse
it up like this
so i think that was a mistake honestly
it's gonna
the vendor thing is a big change like
that's huge i mean you i used to just
stand at
zavala and be like all right
so now you're gonna have to like farm
your ass off doing you know public
events
you know a few other activities that i
need to test out the game
i don't have as many as probably some of
you guys do but it's like i've got 5000
crucible tokens for example
what am i going to use those on now now
nothing dude
like basically nothing yeah shards
really
you can take the spider oh we're getting
there don't worry he'll put a pin
they said they said that they are
they're
doing a vendor refresh for armor but
they kind of never said weapons so
they're probably adding maybe a few more
crucible and vanguard weapons but other
than that
like it's gonna be more anonymous
autumns i guess
how many more reissues are we anonymous
autumn oh my gosh
oh yeah no i've had way too many of
those as well but yeah it's like you
said the whole i will say when they
switched over to the world loot pool
that is not what the world loophole is
in my head because when they're like hey
all the vendors have these 30 different
weapons i'm like you just took the
identity out of
crucible weapons from shacks and
vanguard weapons from there yeah
why is zavala dropping uh a last hope
right like what's the point of that that
that was a weird change and i don't know
why i really need to
do a vendor refresh for you yeah oh yeah
complete yeah i missed those man it
added an excitement like you said it
added an excitement and added an
individuality to each vendor and a
purpose and
i missed that from d1 and i don't know i
don't know if
the vibe i'm getting like is a resource
thing man like they just
they got all these bucket list things of
what they want to do and i know
we'll touch the luke smith thing but
didn't they say um
from uh from a resource standpoint
they're almost
less than half than when they had i mean
how about half of what they had
activated they can't do with victorious
and high
yeah they can't do what they did with
force and that was yeah you said the
luke smith one
he had that twitch gaming podcast
interview and it's just he basically
stated it's like
we're probably never gonna make
something as big as forsaken yeah again
and that's like that's an eye-opener to
some people saying hey is this forsaken
is there a secret third enceladus
destination or whatever
we're getting cosmodrome and we're
getting europa but europa is going to be
big and this is going to be bigger than
shadow keep which is exciting because
we're getting europa which has been
developed for like 12 000 years
it's been in development forever and we
also get to bring back cosmodrome which
is kind of a
you know nice skin paint and then
they're going to kind of build that one
up as well
but that does kind of tell you what the
resources are like
can they do things like a dreaming city
and a tangled shore
plus the strikes and everything we got
with that the
the good news is that they can bring
destinations and content back more
resource efficiently and that's why
we're getting the remade vaulted glass
you know in a few seasons
right because you know it's not it's not
the same resources as completely
redesigning a raid
and so you have a lot of content from
destiny one to draw from and then
hopefully
because the vast majority of people were
not here for destiny one so to them it's
totally new content
and the destiny one vets are more than
happy to get you know a d2 fatebringer
you can hopefully just get a lot of
resources from that maybe they expand
the team maybe they open a new
a bungee office somewhere or something
like that like um
and and then maybe you do work your way
towards having the resources to do
forsaken i mean destiny is
one of the biggest franchises out there
and it's just like
it's remarkably consistent like it'll
obviously drop off when it kind of dies
but just people keep coming back people
keep spending money
so they certainly again that's the good
news is that they can have a lot of
content to draw from and even existing
content they bring back titan at some
point
in six years from now or whatever it's
and it's gonna people are gonna be
thrilled about it
yeah yeah absolutely man i mean this is
like i said
you just want to see them continue to
improve evolve there's a lot of stuff
going on with them i will say shout out
to the new faces on the stream that i
never saw before
they look like they're hiring i saw some
new people i was like oh i ain't never
seen this brother before what's going on
you don't see a lot of cool faces but um
you just hope that
that continues to ramp up and you know
we got to be realistic with certain
expectations based on studio size so
yeah i mean we've joked about it before
to say it's like how much are we
expecting to get from
you know beyond light we kind of figured
shadow keep was like a buffer they were
trying to figure out they were getting
on their own that's a whole lot of stuff
going on
and then they are taking europa and this
is where it's going to be kind of
interesting to see
how big is europa because they probably
had built the framework for europa about
six years ago so they had something to
work with but i mean granted they
probably built it mostly from the ground
up
then they're going to turn around and do
a brand new destination for
witch queen because they've said each
expansion has a new one it's like
that's where it's going to see like what
scale do they have in their pipeline
again for how much bandwidth do they
have to build
another new nest donation and another
dude destination within
we talked about the cadence of the
seasons are they going to try and shrink
it and get back to that september gap
because
if young light would have come out in
september we would have been all loving
this thing because november 10th is
stupid busy full of everything
oh my gosh yeah like this one not
cyberpunk anymore hey i'm happy about
that one now seriously
[Music]
idiots happy cyberpunk you know what
cyberpunk doesn't want to say they
scared dude they're like they suck
at destiny cyberpunk the cyberpunk devs
saw that like revenant gameplay and
they're like oh my god dude like
you're out of here but yeah
what they smoke honestly from what i
hear that game probably needs to go to
like april
but i mean it won't you think that
game's development is bad
infinite oh my god dude the guy that's
the best that's the best storyline it's
like the
the main guy leaves leaves then they
like
pay who knows how much to bring him back
and now he left again it's like he
was like i'm done bro he's like peace
i think the ambition of that turning
into like an open world style is
probably biting them and they'll just
like
scope creep or whatever you want to call
it just like it's they're trying to do
a lot let's call it what it is it needs
to be a 2022
mismanaged bad studio it's just it's
just what it is
and i'm an xbox guy but i gotta call it
how i see it bro like it's just
it's mismanagement at the top and once
you have this much
turnover and and stuff like that now
they brought statman
and he's taking chris lee's like it's
crazy i mean that's
not a narrative lead in like three
months before the game was supposed to
launch and you're going
you're starting over is what it sounds
like yeah yeah literally it's
it was a politely i'm taking your job
the dude that
who show whoever showcased whatever they
showcasing april with the craig memes
he's out of here so yeah yeah so
you you guys that's responsible for
craig we gotta we got a new team in
place
and it's the new direction we go away
from which you know it makes you
thinkful
of bungie like they have a clear
direction they're going in like
very clear and and i think that so much
so that they felt safe enough
to announce not only beyond light but
witch queen and lightfall like that's
pretty unprecedented right now never
like at no point you know destiny one
came out and then we had
the taken king originally comet comics
reference we got alpha beta players in
here what's up hey that d1 alpha vet
twitter account got nothing on me
but listen uh they had that but like
i could you imagine when that came out
they were like a rise of iron next i
guess rise of iron like they were
working on destiny
2 yeah they couldn't make it in time
they made a rise of iron but even then
it's
destiny 2 forsaken and forsaken we have
absolutely no idea
about shadow key so this is like really
unprecedented that they're like here are
the next three big expansions
like we have a clear overarching
storyline that will connect
everything to this light fall yes it's
really interesting they're doing that
but it's good news because it's like
they have a vision and like
i said with with halo they clearly
have are all over the map but
last point we'll move on from 353 i do
feel for them because i always say this
343
it's not their baby right it's like
they're a
foster parent in a way like they didn't
create
halo it was bungee that left and then
they were forced to now live up to this
expectation
yeah to do so i do feel that i'm not
making excuses you know i'm saying i'm
just saying like
i do feel that if i wonder how they
would do if they had their own
franchise that was built by them new
ground up kind of thing you know
it's i i'll just say quickly like i'll
make excuses if they have like an
impossible job like where it's
they have to be extremely loyal to the
franchise to halo or halo vets and be
like this isn't halo this is trash
right and yet they need to be innovative
enough
so that they're not like you're just
copying halo this is it feels like the
same as all these other games
like they can't do both at the same time
it's
really difficult tough spot tough spot i
definitely agree
i mean like something like halo 2 and
halo 3 did do that where it was still
unmistakably halo but it added enough
new things
that it was also completely innovative
it's
very very hard to do that destiny 2 went
freaking backwards from destiny 1.
and then now finally we're forwards
again i think like
with beyond light like if we just got
rid of everything in the middle and it
was like destiny
one to beyond light we're like yeah we
have new
new darkness subclasses and we're
continuing this way i think that
storyline would make
like that would make sense but we kind
of spent
what four years kind of yeah getting
stuff back
there they're honestly basically with
the destiny content vault
they're almost taking the red war
campaign and saying that didn't kind of
happen
um
doesn't it feel almost like they're kind
of like like they're finally getting on
track like with beyond light and and
again they announced that trio
yep it feels like it's like almost
restarting like now we're exploring
this yes yeah and this is just like this
is destiny this isn't even destiny 2
anymore we have a stranger back it's
kind of like we've gone full
circle circle hope their episode 7 is
better than star wars episode
seven and will be pretty good hey no it
can't possibly be worse actually yeah
well game of thrones season eight as a
whole
there you go yeah that's a bad one
that's a bad season eight
no i will say those we got to we see
this new arc coming of
truly the next trilogy as they called it
somewhere in one of these 14 videos
we've had
43 okay 43 sorry i miscounted um
the darkness subclasses
is yes yes
yeah boy again caught that before paul
tassie did the article i caught it right
away i noticed we went over
i was like yeah i caught that
it was like just barely an inventory
screen i just know it said darkness
subclasses
plural now it could have been spelling
mistake it could just be like that
maybe but just the the way the ui was
set up right
too much yeah you have you know right
now you have it was like gunslinger and
then you have the two little modules on
the side
for arc and void and
i think we all thought there'd just be
another module mm-hmm so now it's
darkness now we're switching
and you're good right you just have the
the three little great circles and you
just click stop
darkness or uh stasis and you click
whatever the other two are right
but it's now it's a totally different
knob that says switch to darkness
subclasses and it completely switches
and then when you hover over because he
kind of barely went back over and you
can see it say
switch to light subclasses and also in
plural again
because obviously we have multiple light
subclasses so that to me says like
dude and and then luke smith comes in
and says
stasis is oh what do you say it might
even happen
or something like that he basically
commented on it he literally said he's
like stasis
is our introduction to the darkness
subclasses
he like caught like again and it's real
oh and
like there's no way after like seven
different quotes and like you know
it's all just mistakenly plural like
they know what they're doing
um and i think that again the way the ui
is designed
i think that it's very possible that we
get and
more darkness subclasses and
there's three like subclasses there's
three light elements and they've
announced those
three expansions all having to do with
the darkness
so could it be like with which queen we
get like poison and then
we get like the veil powers or something
shadows kind of what i was thinking
there like almost like whatever the
taken have bro whatever
i want those powers if i could make my
well i could be a taken
knight or a taken captain i'm done i
just need the [ __ ]
shoot invincible fire that kills you in
0.1 seconds
and then also make your allies
completely invincible to damage like the
vex
literally most and then you can clone
yourself like the freaking scions and
just run around me now what are you
gonna do dude i mean that's the most op
subclass for sure it could be being
taken
absolutely well maybe that's what we get
from savithoon i'm still i still think
the hive has to be green
that's why exactly i think that's what
that has to be
and just have like different things
around because there's definitely is
like a
very clear like poise like thor does it
the necrotic grips
we're seeing it's like a theme here yeah
yeah
i agree but yeah the light fall oh and
then the question is that's the key is
like okay so we have six subclasses
somewhere around lightfall's end
where like how do they take that into
what's next is that like
shout out to the balance team oh my god
that's going to be a hard task shout out
to them 1200 grenades later
do you guys want a crazy theory do it
and you can clip this and then
clip it let's go now listen all right
here's a crazy theory
light fall comes and we lose our light
subclasses they literally take
all the light subclasses away and it's
just the three darkness subclasses that
you can choose between
and then the next trio is like us
because we we basically lose and we
essentially
you could even say join the darkness
with light fall the light like it
would imply that light loses that battle
then
over the next course of whatever bungie
kind of reintroduces
the light subclasses but they're remade
somewhat they have some new abilities
and they're importantly redesigned
after the darkness of classes fragments
and all that
ex exactly because right now like you
have two very different types of
subclasses like that
just normal node like attunements and
then the a lot more
in-depth customization and i think
obviously people would rather have that
customization
going forward with the light subclasses
so that's a great excuse for them to
like take them away and then reintroduce
them remade
no don't listen you might be on to
something
i was like we've kind of joked about
some of that before the other idea was
like
if we get darkness in this one are they
over the course of seasons or time gonna
like
rehash the other ones like is next
season potentially going to be like hey
this is an arc based one your arc one
gets the aspects in fragments and then
so i kind of wondered if they would do
it that quickly
but honestly like yours would be more
theoretically would make more sense in
lore aspect because
you would actually have a reason to lose
them and the way to bring them back in
that different way because right now
it'd be kind of arbitrary to be like
okay the arc now functions like this
like
i really like how that oh oh i made a
big mistake telling that whole theory
without my tin foil
it doesn't it doesn't count now he
didn't have the hat on it doesn't count
yeah i literally had it sitting behind
me what was i thinking
salute to the temple listen
i i think you're on to it bro cause at
the end of the day it's like oh shout
out scarole what's going on what's going
on
in the chat but yeah it's like i i do
think because at the end of the day
we're gonna have the stasis subclass
we're gonna have these new dark this
subclasses
the other stuff i'm not gonna say it's
gonna be obsolete but it's gonna need to
be reworked right so what better way
yeah to do what you said right where
they either remove and it's light
fall and then there's a periodic kind of
progression of reintroducing things
getting back and getting back to the
light and
it makes sense dramatically story yo
that's fine you want to put that me out
you want to it bro yeah you want to
yeah and they're definitely regardless
of with if that exact trajectory happens
there has really got to be at some point
them
remaking the current subclasses like
this yes seems like subclasses 2.0 but i
think they knew
they would be taking off like they'd be
way too much work to do that with
all of them because you have so many so
much loot because you have all these
different aspects for like the existing
subclasses
so i think to reintroduce them like one
at a time would certainly make a lot of
sense
right however they do it over seasons or
as you're saying in a much later state
they will eventually this is like they
even called like subclasses kind of like
a beta state for this is they
at one point that was said as their
build into it i'm just kind of curious
as you take stuff like
hammers for example for a titan and
you've got sunbreaker you've got
the big burning mall you've got sunspots
and you've got the throwing hammers like
are those now gonna be
like the aspects to change the way the
subclass works are we just like gonna
whittle it down and
change like are we gonna be losing like
i mean what is scarro saying in chat
he's like
no it wasn't scary somebody was just
saying it's like bottom tree
i was cool guy bottom tree dawn blade
like if you lose one of your favorite
subclasses like
and they don't give you a way to get it
back there's definitely going to be but
hell to pay to the community for sure
about that because it's like i think
what we're seeing now is the
evolution of the subclass like what
we're seeing now with the fragment stuff
and
they want to cut in my opinion they want
to get back to some semblance of choice
and configuration okay absolutely no
absolutely and if you look at
how it's formatted you just pick it's
like you have your like melee slot your
jump slot and you hover over it and just
comes down so hypothetically
if it was the solar version you could ha
and literally your super takes up a slot
but there's only one option if you hover
over it nothing comes down
right so they're saying two things that
are one if they remade it that you could
potentially just hover over
like you said sunbreaker and then you
have burning mall to select friends you
can choose between multiple supers
yep but they're also saying maybe that
you know
at some point whether they've introduced
more darkness subclasses or not
we have a forsaken possibility where
we don't necessarily get a new darkness
subclass maybe we just get a new super
for stasis
like we got new supers for the other
elements right
and and that could be like if they're
not ready to introduce a whole new
element in a whole new subclass they're
not ready for poison
but they're ready for hey the behemoth
has like something else it has like a
a mace or something i don't know like
you know like so that's another very
interesting possibility is if we got
these new subclasses could we be getting
like an a new super treatment at some
point
right the the potential for variants and
stuff there's a lot of stuff here man
i think this is definitely the direction
that they they intend on going
i just think it's one of those
situations from a time and resource
standpoint
they can't do it all at once so we are
going to now
you know systematically put this thing
out per expansion or whatever and
tinfoil theory would require a lot of
resources so
will that actually happen probably not
to be honest but who knows
yeah it does feel like at some point
they're going to probably change them
one at a time we'll just have to see how
it happens because to do all three
subclasses and some big upheaval
yeah remember that's a bit substantial i
mean this this is a little out there but
remember when they had like arc week
solar week
whatever and they like when they did
that they had like pretty substantial
overhauls like even like new abilities
sometimes
i still remember arc quick was the
biggest let down ever
on the calendar from the better all
right it was trendy
which is trash what is this are you
gonna be like is yeah
abilities gonna be everywhere no it was
literally that was the same
refresh that was changing the subclass
of sandbox changes
and rework like for me to geek and me
was like yo
they reworked you know saying like so
many aspects arc web came out at that
time for top tree i believe um
you know stormcaller and stuff like that
and it really
definitely changed something out from a
content perspective yes
trash but from a from a
meta perspective there was some
substantial changes and i was it really
was yeah these older classes are now
effective and i'm excited to play that
stuff
can they have an exotic armor month or
something where they rehash all the
useless exotic armor
yeah breach there's a lot of work that
needs done because there's a lot of
stuff that doesn't get a lot of love so
eon swift's baby oh my god those need a
whole
that would be a really cool thing
dude i mean like somehow with somehow
they take up like 50
of your nightfall drops i've had so many
of those possible
i don't i know it's ridiculous i think i
got like
two in one day and i didn't have that
many challenges that i did or whatever
two of my three drops or something i was
like get out of my inventory and they
both and that's like my highest drop is
probably like a 69 stat roll
on an a on uh safe i was just pissed
oh dude i got like a 69 e on swift and i
just hate my life for it yeah i'm like
you just shut it down and be like hey
stream's over i'll see you guys later
yeah and it was like crack stats too i'm
like can you not give me this for the
dune marchers or something like come on
why you gotta
anything come in here at this eons of
guys well i do wanna ask you guys
um four hundred dollars before you
continue
what's up before you continue we just
spoke about exotic armor
yo when is exotic armor catalyst gonna
come they said that that was coming
back in freaking war mine they're like
we're gonna experiment with exotic
armored catalysts soon
it's been years bro come on exotic
armor needed you at the campfire bruh
we've been preaching this
exotic armor lack of love for
so long bro it literally gets
just neglected but continuing with you
bro no
at some point they gotta do it and also
they gotta
realistically they should really be
introducing catalysts
essentially whenever they introduce a
new exotic or maybe one season later
because like
an exotic without a catalyst is like
objectively worse like i don't
make masterwork shards like right or
sorry i don't make orbs
of light that's huge like forms of the
power now by the way
especially especially they're changing
in names
especially for uh like primaries not
light
yeah true but especially for primaries
like i'm never gonna if i'm gonna use a
primary and pve i gotta use one that's
mastered
the world like so so yeah they really
need to finish that off for the exotics
oh yeah big time somebody's like ice
fall mantle catalyst make the overshield
last longer
oh my gosh it's like it's already gonna
be busted but hey i'm a titan i get to
enjoy it for a little while
so yeah yeah we're gonna get to enjoy it
for like
five minutes and get it's gonna get
smashed into the garage bunji be letting
y'all rock with them without them nerves
man y'all be getting
as soon as the other warlocks and
hunters get something that's broke
they'd be like yo we gotta
nerf that and meet effective immediately
okay hunters are fine
whoever's on the balance team be letting
the titans rock for a couple of seasons
with something yeah you know what
you know why because remember when they
did guardian games and the hunters were
like
crying about guardian games and
literally
the t and the hunters literally like
said that the titans were like cheating
and making duplicates just the titans
are making duplicate accounts and then
bungie had to come out and show them the
in-game data you cry babies
here's the literal data that shows that
you're just not trying
dude that was the best dude the hunters
are like
they're you can't even if you're a
hunter main you gotta keep quiet for
like three more years because of that
that was like the biggest embarrassment
like
the titan just came in with our little p
brains and just
punched our way to victory dude and it
was just the best thing ever and
warlocks
warlocks right i gotta admit they were
like up there for just
viving the entire time and just coming
in second place
the numbers for like titans and war and
hunters like going up and down
warlocks they're just viving the whole
time
and like never got upset they're just
like like second place is good i don't
know
yeah they'll take that that silver
they're hey they're on the podium
[Laughter]
when bungie released the data proving
the hunters were just not trying like
that was classic they had to everybody's
like they're cheating
there's like videos like it was like the
dumbest idea was like titans are
cheating because they're making
new classes and just redoing it it's
like well you can make any
new class they're like no but the titans
doing it's like what's your proof that
only titan's doing it's like well
because they're winning it's like that's
not
that's not how it works dude there's no
however that doesn't make any sense
you know the hunters of our lives was
tight bro they was not feeling y'all
that way that guardian yo bro they was
not feeling hey
that statue is sadly fitting for what we
got because it's sitting over there next
to the volley like a afterthought so
it's fine it's not like a big grand
statue it's this little like
triumph that got tripped over in the
corner i hate to admit it too silver and
bronze
for look pretty dope for the classic
gold gold's a little
too much dude it's like yeah i don't
need that much bling in my life i'm
sorry
exactly dude i've never
yeah so i will say speaking of bling uh
you guys are about to spend all of it
trying to get your enhancement prisms
400 legendary shards per prisoner dude
who would ever spend 400 legendary
shards on a prism
that sounds sick so how many shards do
you have cacao cause i know you got to
have a crap i have like 14 000
and i got like six yeah sixteen thousand
something like that yeah so it's like
with mine i could buy
37 prisms i'm like i could use my prisms
and i couldn't even fill it back up with
14
000 shards i'm like the person who walks
around with like 500 is like
no never it's crazy because like
who needs to buy shards like new and
casual players
right because i can just get do gms and
i'll get
all or sorry not charts prisms all you
know my prisons from gm's right
easy like super easy so it's targeted
towards new players that
you know can't do a gm they can't
complete a gm so they need to buy it
but then it's like dude for for those
players
400 shards is so much that's a lot bro
hey
oh my god dude yeah spider is definitely
hustling out here i mean hustling out
here he's putting in some work like
this bro this is just like it just
doesn't make any sense
it's like this i feel like the spider is
like the pawn shop so he's like best i
can do
is 400. like yeah he like the poor stuff
come on
yeah see what it is is they they got rid
of
the the sequential increase right
because before memo you you trade some
stuff in and the price go up then the
price go up so now they're trying to do
this flat thing
but um yeah it's like the only thing i
agree with is the
legendary shot removal as a as a um
currency to buy from because who really
is gonna
come down for that but the the prices
for what they're asking for these shards
or these prisms or whatever
to me seem aimed at you guys which is
the
content creator that has all this
success
exactly who it's for yeah that's
literally what this is like
and they want you guys to clean it out
that that's how i look at it here's the
thing if you're a good content creator
who actually plays the game
you again you can do gm's bro like
i can do a gm easily like absolutely i
don't
need i will never buy i like there's
already you can already buy shards right
right and the return on them from the
gunsmith isn't even great
it's just a very confusing like again
you would expect it to be
for newer players but like a newer
player should never give away 400
legendary shards for a prism like
no way dude i i just thought
weirdly enough the masterwork pricing
change makes a lot more sense
whereas you can only buy five but
overall it's cheaper
it's like okay that makes sense i agree
i agree
because that that and that is aimed at
and will help the new players
yes because it's like hey i need they
probably don't need much more than five
yeah a day and it's overall cheaper for
them but you know you don't you can't go
like
insane and i buy like a thousand like
right
off the start yeah man i'm with you
but sticky oh i mean i just thought it
was ridiculous when i saw it because i
was just i literally pulled up i was
like all right how many shards do i have
i can buy this mini this i'm never gonna
do this this is ridiculous
and then we have the enhancement core
switch as well where you're like hey
it's 10 20 40 80 160. i don't know who
pays that much for him i occasionally if
i see spider i'm like i'll buy a couple
shards
now literally you could currently buy
two for the price of what it's going to
be one in the future so
i guess they did it yeah like i don't
think i've ever bought an enhancement
core from spider
like ever or
like to slowly build my collection i'm
like oh i have like fifteen thousand
shards i'll buy like one or two but as
soon as it gets to forty i'm like as
soon as he goes up to forty then i'm
like uh
you got so many you get so many shards
from if you do
and even just a normal amount of raids
you get the
uh masterwork versions the curated
versions a decent amount and each of
those give you seven
right yeah i mean to me it's like that
intermediate
skill person you know what i'm saying
and also beat pit
pit gives you a guaranteed masterwork
there's seven shards right there
pit's not even hard three people pit
easy bro
cac is in the defense of the casual base
here
hold on hold on oh oh oh normally gloves
come out you can't be right
normally you'd be right but this season
we got falling guillotine
it's a joke of an encounter dude you
literally just duped the ball
which everyone knows how to do because
of the current public event and then you
throw up a bubble or a well and you just
spin to win the entire time and you will
two people could could beat that boss in
one phase easy with falling guillotine
too many times with aries do it bro
it's so easy right now you're absolutely
right you know say the problem is
that mid-tier the beginning level person
they don't got those strats that you
know man they don't know they're coming
into the game what's this
what's uh what's this gun what does this
carry me through
this hence why there's a lot of guides
out there that have dummies on it i
don't know who makes those though i
forget the guy
shots fired sometimes it's cool
hey clearly that's who i'm making it for
you know what i'm saying but you know
but
it's uh it really heresy is like easier
than ever
it's just like obviously finding finding
a group is the hard part yeah if you
but it's like just using lfg people
always like
the the problem with lmg lfgs is yeah
they're toxic they're toxic
and you know know what to do
don't unless come on that's intimidating
to a new guy come on
come on but it
you just have to find one you just have
to find one good group
and you're golden right and then then
you have experience to help you find
more
and even if you okay so you play with
two guys one guy's super toxic the other
guy is chill add that other guy
and then try to get someone else with
with him hey
now you can make an lfg and you're
looking for one player
and like dude it's so easy a lot of like
players are just hardcore it's like i
just want two teammates
they could be basically you know
completely new i can still
basically solo it like i see so many
people who
say oh i had a toxic lfg experience and
it's like i'm
never going back it's like okay well
it's like how many times have you tried
lg
once so they had one bad experience and
they're like never again it's like well
it you just count that as a failed
attempt it's like just keep going in
there
and and again if you meet someone nice
meet someone good
one out of six people in a raid lfg if
they're nice or good which is a pretty
decent chance
add them and then you can just slowly
build a team build up
absolutely i agree but people they they
try one lfg
it doesn't work out and then they
complain about it on twitter for eight
hours a day and then it's like dude use
that twitter
time to be making up a new lfg
that's what we do it's so true though
like i mean that's kind of one of those
things
any game you've ever played online i
will say just really quickly i will say
so i'm not like crapping on the casual
players like again i know
how toxic lfgs are the best example is
when my squad was
my team was the only team on console to
beat
uh crown of sorrow yes sir one of my
guys from that team who had the emblem
again there's six people in the world
who had that emblem on playstation was
trying to get a team and they said he
didn't have enough clears and kicked him
out
and he's the guy the guy part of the
team that beat it day one this guy knows
what he's doing
so yes i know lfgs are toxic as
crap but it only takes one you only
gotta find
one good one and you're set or and again
keep adding players
that you play with that are that you
find the lpgs that are good
it's always the one toxic guy that ruins
it but the other guy you know the other
five guys in the raid team are usually
pretty chill right
yeah so you know no i feel your point
like i said i i
understand both sides i understand your
point and i understand
for the casual guy sometimes that first
experience is scarring man
it really is you know no zeno no whisper
you're out of here bro must have
literally ever like must have the you
know
we're joking that new raids are going to
come out and the lfg posts the next day
are going to be like must-have 24-hour
emblem must have raid exotic must have
five clear
must-have jacket
six months later you'll get it yeah
exactly oh my god
dude i mean there's a silver lining to
all this stuff at least all your
sparrows are gonna load quickly
so that gotta go fast hey that's
actually good i was like that's a good
thing
and now the key is if you have a sparrow
that has the instant loader on it
dump it and go get the one that actually
gets you better perks so you can
actually have reloader
and dodging and all that stuff that's
better honestly apparently the best
spare out there is the
scourge of the past one because you have
the i guess extra help
yeah or they shoot you less yeah they
target you less oh yeah so you that
thing has like three perks on it but
generally i mean that's a good thing
which is
so one person did say the speed demon
also does the auto reloading as well
so you're actually kind of potentially
losing both so
if you like those perks just you know
keep pulling those sparrows so you get
them
but the fact that like this is
everybody's wanted this for six years as
well so this is one of those finally
little quality of life things we're like
oh it took you long enough
i was like everybody's always wanted
this make all sparrows like 160. right
isn't there a few 150s bumping around
yeah
that is true and it's like if it was
throws 150
see ya like i'm never going to use it
ever can there be a 180 raid sparrow
please
like what is scary why not anybody care
about reload no speed
no i don't think anybody actually cares
i'm just saying you can do something
besides make sure it reloads fast
i literally think the reason they're
capped at 160 is just because they like
did the tests and like
that is enough time to get through like
a loading zone that they can actually
load it if they're any faster
it might like hit a limit that's really
why it probably makes sense on the
hardware i was worried about them yeah
especially pertaining to the power
racing league that we haven't seen
hey maybe maybe after lightfall in this
trilogy that they do they finally
dropped the old consoles and it's only
next-gen and pcs only and we can see
what else they do from there
it's gonna be a few years before they
can drop but they're like yeah that yeah
you said maybe after this trilogy right
yep yeah okay then that that
would be reasonable timing for doing
that it feels like because we're gonna
get cross play with
witch queen and then the light falls
gonna be who knows and then at that
point like if you don't have a ps5 and
you want to play
destiny season 10 or year 10 whatever
that is
time to go next gen because we want to
make it for that like at that point
are you shutting the 30 frames per
second gabriel
no i'm not yes actually i am at that
point
you vip them sir
i want to see what destiny looks like if
it's made for that stuff that's the key
the flag that those guys are
holding back to development 100 100 and
i'm trying not to cuss but yes
hey your eyes can't even see faster than
30 frames stop hating bro
nowadays with xbox being like yeah you
can finance an xbox one s for like 25
dollars a month and stuff
and still get oh get the dude get
it's going to be so easy to upgrade like
that was the thing it's like for some
people getting a 300
console that's you know that's too much
for them but it's like
hey 35 or 25 bucks a month
yeah i mean i just imagine when you're a
you know a teenager or a kid you're
trying to convince your parents like
please please what i mean and now dude
now you can be like mom
35 i'll pay you 35 bucks a month i can
give you 35 bucks a month and they'll
probably be like okay
i'm sure it's getting done groceries get
done yeah
like that's the thing the pc gamers like
to think they're on top and technically
they are but it's like convinced yeah
mom i need
two thousand dollars for just my
graphics card she's gonna get out of
here
no i went to 30 90 so i was thinking
you can't even get a 30 90 right now
what are you trying to do to me
yeah exactly and you're like mom it's
only 700 bucks it's like and then you're
like but then i would it's
like at the size of a small bus so i
would need a new
ma i would need a new motherboard i need
more ram
i need a better i need a different power
system i need a different cooling system
can i get that 4k 144 it's monitor to 2
with it i need that i need it yeah so
that's what consoles are for consoles
are a great introduction to gaming
scaro's like i feel pretty dude
scarole i'm with you i'm waiting for a
new graphics card and a monitor as well
so i want these things i'm with you man
trust me
like exactly three people on planet
earth were able to just take their
graphics card out and replace it with a
39er
everyone else had to get a completely
different rig i'm telling you thanks
thanks no doubt man fun times
well apparently eververse is gonna have
like what
nine seasons basically go back three
seasons and everything from one to then
will be in
in there i would like to see them just
drop more bright engrams
like when you get to that season 100
level
just once you get one above 100 it's
like every three you're like oh i got
three levels i got a bright engram and
that's it i would love to see them do a
little bit more
post 100 just something i don't know
what but something
yeah i i'm fine with it like i just kind
of take it as i get them and then
sometimes i get
you know exotic ornaments i'm like oh
cool yeah i go on for the thunderlord
recently and i'm like oh sweet and
i was using it farm and strikes when it
was heavyweight and arc burn and it's
just like
i just kind of get it as i i don't
really care about that stuff and you
gotta
like to them it's like i'm okay with
stuff like that whereas it is purely
cosmetic and it's okay
bungee's gotta make some money and if
you wanna you know spend some money to
get the dopest looking ornament that has
like point two inches of a longer barrel
so
like you know fallout plays so full i
can make the video i did yeah exactly
the longer the long barrel is always
longer
i mean that's that's what it's a little
sketchy when it's like okay if there's
actual range advantage oh
it's like it's super slight but for me i
think the big thing is like
and this happened in call of duty world
war ii it's like
yes it's a purely cosmetic ornament it
doesn't have any changes on stats or
damage or anything but
is it not pay to win if you have a
substantially better sight picture
because for it was really noticeable in
call of duty world war ii because
you it took up attachment slots to put
on a site
so you would have certain cosmetic oh
you know only cosmetically different
guns that have way better yeah
way better iron sights and you're like i
don't need to use a sight with this like
i can use
other attachments this is a huge
advantage destiny it's not that extreme
but like
man certain like exotics have like a
clean sight and you put it on you're
like
this is way easier time i like the the
uh the sate 14
ornament on vigilance wing yeah it's a
better site it's cleaner
than the actual osiris you know the
little the what you call it things
blocking your 100 i mean recently with
the uh cold denial
the the the they changed it now but the
ornament in the uh season's past
had like way higher zoom factor it's
just super clean and it was like oh well
this is just
this is objectively better right
like so i wonder what they're going to
do
at some point they gotta address that
maybe they should like try to like keep
the parameters of like keep the same
amount of stuff on your screen and not
have a super clean sight
uh compared to one that's not because it
does matter it really it does matter it
doesn't matter
i'm a big fan of them actually with the
ottomans just reintroduce it because
sometimes i got to be real
at least especially with armor there's
some armor that the functionality of the
armor is
really good but it's ugly as hell and
i'm like
as a warlock we got a style baby so i i
need
like like putting for example i don't
use this weapons one too much but this
the the ornament to the stag
do you ever see that one oh that one
gets fire
the perk freaking sucks like oh when
you're dead or something you'll put out
a rift and it's like thanks exactly
it's a useless flag over there i'm okay
come save me i'm okay
yeah but it's just like over here
there's a rift near me you can find me
next to my rift that didn't
help five minutes ago i did riff but i
just love
exotics that you know definitely give
you that extra you know
oomph to use it because it looks better
now you know i'm saying so
yeah well now with transmog
dude it's gonna be wild with transmog
like uh
really any armor is going to be open and
you can just like as soon as that comes
in season 13 i think it is or
maybe a little bit after it's like it's
like dude that's crazy i can just have a
whole trials of osiris get up and not
you know have to worry about putting on
ornaments and all this stuff i think so
do you think at that point they've got
to do something for
at that point if they're ever going to
do any revamp to armor whether it be
like mods or stats matter or anything
like that
because then if you don't if you have
like a set that you like the way it
looks
either the new armors that drop from new
activities have to be absolutely fire
for you to want to go get them because
you can make yourself look like all the
cool old stuff
or they got to give you a reason to get
like new armor and put that stuff on
there i'm just kind of curious when
transmog comes
well then what's your incentive to be
like well hey here's this new season arm
and be like
dude i look like a boss over here and
i'm already good like
what's the point so i'll kind of be
curious how they balance that equation
i think the simple answer to that is
like if you look at how they're changing
the armor where they have a legacy mod
slot then they have a combat mod slot
from like season of dawn
down to i think it includes beyond light
for the
light empowered stuff and the war mine
sell stuff so potentially if they just
have
a different like a year four mod slot
and it goes from season 13
to witch queen and all that applies like
mods from that year right and so every
year
you have an incentive to get some good
stat roll
armor because they can equip certain
yearly mods
right and so it you know it's not as
intense of a breakdown of like
you know when it was every season that
was pretty brutal yeah
yeah i i do love and i'm looking forward
to the exotic slot sorry
um having exotics finally having the
damn
seasonal mod right they're supposed to
be adding that
that changes everything like yes i mean
oh my goodness that changes everything
because you know
often if you're making a really like a
pure warming cell build you had to
not even put on an exotic because you're
like dude i need power of rasputin or
whatever
now oh you can put it on and it ah man
that's gonna be got my builds bro i got
my my loosen blades my
supercharge yeah
talking about yeah charging lights gonna
have some fun times with that as well
100 yeah mm-hmm what else we got
uh i mean that's mostly it honestly it's
like we always have a lot of stuff to
cover and we blow through it if we have
no topics we get off on tangents but we
also gotta
respect this man's time he's got some
stuff to go do so yes sir yes
i do want to wrap this one up um i did
want to ask one more question this is
kind of what we'll wrap it up
what is one thing you hope to be
surprised by in beyond light
the cackington rick cackington
i want i want the raid
weapons to be unique i wanted to go back
to
where we have in like uh what's it
called wrath of the machine weapons
where yes
you had focus firefly you had steel uh
you know medulla and the fourth times
the term or whatever it was called
preaching and and and those were and
triple double and you had
troubles those are perks you could only
get on those specific grade weights
great [ __ ]
absolutely right now like with the
garden of salvation great weapons are
boring they're so boring and i'd want to
go back to that where it's like
you know maybe at some point if they're
on the raid weapons they can be added
into the world loop pool
at a later time or whatever that's okay
but at least initially i want to see
some actual
uniqueness within the raid loop yep yeah
i could not agree
more yeah on fire brother so i've been
we've been preaching that for the
longest i
completely agree with you that's what
made wrath of the machine so cool
and one of my favorite rape is raised
from a reward standpoint
there was probably no ray better and i
also think about things like
obviously we have the pinnacle weapons
that are going away but think about
something like retrospect that has a
cool perk like desperado so now nothing
can get desperado like how cool would it
be to introduce that into a raid weapon
or some new perks
in there so now you incentivize
legendary way weapons the problem they
have been too
focused they've been to speaking of
focus
i know right now absolutely hold on
speaking of focus
advanced.gigi you make sure you use code
khd
uh let's send this man some love there
you go
out of nowhere that's
that segway is like champion style
anyways that was boom that was move sir
no i just i feel like i mean as much as
i love divinity 1k
and all that and anakin it's dope that
should always still be in there
but again it shouldn't be the only
farmable thing that i'm going after i
should be like when i get a raid weapon
it should be intrinsically have
something like that no other weapon has
better than your basic strike weapons
like easily actually
especially especially you know it didn't
matter as much
when it was forsaken how to raid then
uh season the forge had a raid right and
then like it was now
yeah exactly if it's like one new raid a
year like yeah fault of glass is coming
but still if it's one big raid for the
whole year
that raid better have some desirable
loot that it really is going to last a
long time
mm-hmm what about you shout out to
vagabondo i just got a shout out he said
e did you have to do that
for caccus to fill the guesthouse yes
contractual it was contractual that was
his uh
and then get that pop and that was part
of the contract those are my
requirements
no i have more focus over here than i
should so i was like believe me i rip it
all the time but we got him on here so i
may as well give him some love
no sorry questioning oh i was gonna say
what about you what surprise are you
hoping for
um narrative man narrative narrative
beats
um cohesive connections to the next
season you know i i want cool stuff i
think
they're going back to the original
destiny vision which is dope
but i just what like i said i just want
this thing to pay off to be smooth
us to be on the edge of our seat because
look people you know disney who's new
store
destiny has great story unfortunately
it's like buried in stuff that you know
you can't find or it's all out of the
game
but when it's done right man it is
there's
moments and i think they have potential
to have some moments so i'm looking
forward to that in the payoffs and
hopefully osiris can get up off the
floor and handle his business that's
what i'm about for sure
now is juan osiris did not look like a
chump by the end of this just
to get my man back to greatness thank
you my favorite meme was like going into
and when it was your ghost talking it's
like oh cyrus one of the most powerful
guardians of all time
smash cut to him just being like smack
to the ground i was like oh my god
i gotta hold this l again that was
perfect yeah that was amazing
for me honestly it was one of those
things like we're getting a brand new
destination a whole new planet to mess
with we get cosmodrome
we got prophecy and season of arrivals
which was a giant surprise but as much
as i love dungeons i want a surprise
dungeon
that's come on e let's do it
we're doing it you get the rain you're
getting it right
i agree it's dungeon and raid do it
let's go baby dungeons are some of the
best stuff dungeons are some of my
favorite stuff in this whole game
no dutch is a fire what if what if
there's a deep stone crypt
dungeon too and it takes place like it
may be like
it goes like a different way than the
raid or something like that yeah
there's a sign left for the raid turn
right for the dungeon
now dungeon yeah now whoever's going to
check dungeon unlocked after the raid
see that would be cool same way
shattered throne did that like
again i'm with you though for sure
let's pass your guess i'd rather save a
dungeon for a season with no raid
because my thing is we know the middle
seasons be trash
put the is going to be in that dead
season in spring that's one of those
seasons is going to happen
one season with it with a dungeon and
this way we kind of make it you know
the big difference is you pay 40
for this expansion you pay ten dollars
for the other season
so if you're gonna like there's a reason
they pack all the content in one season
down in the chat come on see scarole
there we go
thank you see scary i got you man i got
you you you was on fire then you had to
do that
i supported your raid videos when you're
doing the music tracks man
don't do that now that's all i got
though we got to let this man get out of
here and wrap up so
before we go caccus the work the
platform was yours tell everybody who
sees and hears this thing
what do you got coming where they can
find you i could tell most of them but
dude this one's yours you got a lot of
places where they can find you so
not really where you can find me youtube
just
paccus hd on youtube and i guess i got a
twitter as well at rick cackas
pretty useless is just for memes and uh
what am i doing beyond light stuff when
it happens that's basically it there's a
podcast out there that you do as well
sir
it's sponsored too isn't it yeah it's
spotify advanced gg
baby yeah you can also baby every
wednesday
uh well 9 p.m eastern uh basically talk
about
what platform emtash got banned on
recently
fantastic man holla tell the tasha holla
at us man
he's too busy living in his mansion i'm
made of ferraris from
freaking what's he's got ferraris you
got lamborghinis one of the two
oh dude tash has made it got a mansion
made out of lamborghinis after he did
that gentian impact stuff my man's
popping off that's awesome
the podcast has been a ton of fun
because oh man just whatever
twitch every week does something so dumb
that we get to talk about and it's just
they just never disappoint
they just you're just a content factory
for us and it's amazing
no doubt man salute the cac pulling up
always
you know and i should mention it's
called the real gamer hour podcast
i don't think i've said that yet
probably should yes yes real game of
iowa podcast that's the youtube too
right there sir yeah that's the name
there you go man catch that fantastic
also of shout out to
true vanguard on them and um yo dude
your content
one of the best content creators of the
game rick hackers mad respect for you
man love and one thing i got to shout
you out because one thing i like about
cac he's one of the realest bro like
some some content creators can get a
little hollywood now my man he's always
been
real 100 and i have so many
you know being around a lot of content
creators like he
you sense the genuineness one of the
realest i remember we met back was it
2018 whatever once we met
and we just kicked it and the vibe was
dope so salute to you your continued
success i see you moving and grooving
out here
always a pleasure sir i appreciate that
you know you already know
that's for me yeah lord cognito on
twitter all that good stuff online
podcast on sundays the lord's day
and um yo check us out this week we're
gonna have uh brandon tyrell from ign
we're gonna get it popping with him talk
what's going on in the industry talk
about all the craziness with halo
infinite the shakeups
stuff like that and ps plus new next
generation consoles so check us
out sunday 11 a.m eastern iron law
podcast
on youtube on twitch and of course
lord2gamer.net appreciate the support
the site is growing
really got the love and you know about
that last word podcast with me and my
man e
you already know what time it is with
that so what's up everybody can find you
me e-bot it's everywhere it's easy
twitch twitter youtube you can find me
on all of them
basically kind of you know fill in this
last little 10 days until we all lose
our mind on november 10th
basically and we don't get to sleep
anymore i mean that's the thing anybody
who covers
video games in any aspect of journalism
content creation streaming
nobody's sleeping so they're just kind
of taking a chill right now and that's
what we're all going to be doing so
beyond light is going to be exciting
but sir rick thank you very much for
coming on it is
absolutely pleasure every time we always
have a blast
um but yeah for this episode thank you
guys very much we got to get this man to
the rest of his evening uh for episode
number 126
october 30th it has been
the last word